hey guys this is vidi with max tech and
this is a lenovo's brand-new IdeaPad s9
40 and we're gonna be unboxing it and
comparing it to apples similarly priced
2019 $1,800 MacBook Pro so let's get
this thing out of the box here oh comes
with this nice little fabric sleeve Wow
this thing is tiny surprising because
it's a 14-inch compared to that 13-inch
and Wow it's got this nice aluminum
shell just like the MacBook it's a
little bit darker than the MacBook as
you guys can see just like that slightly
darker alright get rid of this box so
taking a look at the external dimensions
you can definitely tell that the lenovo
is quite a bit longer right here but
it's not as tall it's definitely a bit
shorter on this end interesting this is
actually pretty nice looking got an
aluminium shell right here nice nice
looking chassis and let's open up the
MacBook Pro right next to it and as you
guys can see the layout is really
similar and we've got the small little
drilled out speaker grilles right here
just like the MacBook Pro same layout
for the trackpad but it's quite a bit
smaller as well definitely smaller than
the 13-inch MacBook Pro but overall it
looks pretty similar especially the
hinge here the hinge looks really really
similar and interestingly the speaker
grilles have another grille underneath
so it seems like the speakers might
actually only be coming from that
smaller grille I'm really liking that
the lenovo has the same unibody aluminum
chassis and just by feeling it seems
like it does have quite a bit more flex
maybe it's not as rigid or not as thick
but it does have more flex you can see
this whole thing's flexing compared to
the MacBook Pro which does flex a little
bit but it definitely feels more solid
and like just tapping here like this
feel solid it sounds solid you could
just hear a little bit of stuff like
vibrating in there
and on the outside I'm really loving
this small little subtle Lenovo
logo here it's really nice and clean I
like that they chose to do this kind of
style of branding on it and looks like
we've got this might be for the
speaker's right here this tiny little
grill on both sides and of course you
have the vents in the back the exhaust
vents and some extra vents here which
unfortunately these do get blocked which
kind of sucks if you're gonna have them
on your lap but it's definitely nice to
have and I can actually see two fans
right behind the grills right here so
overall looks pretty good we actually
get just these vents back here the
exhaust vents so we don't get all these
little drilled out holes and we do
actually get some side vents right here
these really really slim profile vents
right there so while I'm setting the
IdeaPad up you guys can see the specs on
your screen right now the IdeaPad is 14
inches it actually has a 4k display and
it comes with an i7 quad-core processor
compared to the i5 in the MacBook Pro
and I'm trying to set this up but it
seems like the battery is dead and
that's something you get a lot with
Windows laptops that comes shipped with
a dead battery
so before I plug it in I want to show
you guys the ports on both of these guys
on the right side you're getting two
fundable three ports right here on the
IdeaPad and you're getting the same
thing on the MacBook Pro tooth on about
three ports and you're also getting the
headphone jack which on the IdeaPad
comes on the other side alongside
another USB C port now this one does not
support the under boat 3 and it's only
USB 3.1 so it's not the fast USB C
speeds that this guy gets and we also
get the headphone jack they're looking
on the other side of the macbook pro we
actually get two ports and they're both
Thunderbolt 3 so they're full speed so
you're getting 4 full speed on this guy
only 2 on the IdeaPad here um in the
settings and I got a prompt for Windows
hello this is actually a really awesome
feature which uses the webcam to
recognize you and login automatically
into Windows without having to put in
your password so as you guys can see
there's this little notch right here at
the top of the display and it might look
a little bit weird actually doesn't look
that bad but you don't get that on the
MacBook Pro the reason you have this
notch though is that you have
extra sensors for windows hello kind of
like face ID so let's go ahead in we're
gonna set this up okay you guys can see
it blinking right there that little red
light there you go just scanned my face
now you guys can see this little pop-up
it's Windows hello and if I just aim it
towards my face there it goes unlocked
just like that automatically you don't
have to type in any password or anything
and already I can tell that this 4k
display is really really sharp
everything looks really great the colors
look pretty good as well so the first
thing we're gonna do is compare these
keyboards definitely not a lot of heat
travel very minimal key travel and it's
not very clicky let's try this out well
I could definitely tell that this
actually feels a lot better the type on
it's just so satisfying to have that
much more key travel and of course on
the MacBook Pro you're getting the touch
bar which not everybody agrees with but
it's definitely there and it comes with
a couple of other perks that help with
video editing performance and security
as well
now for the trackpads the MacBook Pro is
known for having a really nice trackpad
it's apples force touch trackpad which
it actually simulates clicks it does not
move at all it has a motor underneath
and it senses when you click feels
really good you have this very large
surface area to move around and it's
really good at palm rejection when
you're typing so overall this is a
really excellent trackpad and on this
one you're definitely not getting as
much surface area and while it feels
pretty good right now it kind of sucks
because it actually does physically move
so you don't really get an even clicking
feel everywhere so here at the top it's
not even clicking and here it's really
really easy to click and now let's
compare the display quality so far I'm
noticing more saturated colors on the
lenovo and i'm definitely seeing more
detail it actually looks really really
good looking at the macbook pro it
actually looks a little bit soft just
because you're comparing it to the 4k
display on the lenovo and just looking
at it it looks incredibly detailed super
or sharp this display is definitely
really nice definitely better than the
MacBook Pros but one thing to notice is
that it's a bit oversaturated so it's
not asked true to life as a MacBook Pro
which is very very color accurate and
while playing the video the MacBook Pros
Wi-Fi connection was definitely
struggling to keep up
while the lenovo was doing just fine
buffering the video as it goes along in
real time and here you guys can see what
I'm talking about with the aspect ratios
the MacBook Pro can fit more information
on the screen while browsing the web so
it's definitely a better experience
compared to the more widescreen 16 by 9
aspect ratio of the lenovo so with the
displays out of the way let's jump into
a quick speaker comparison test
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
both of these have 720p webcam so I
figured I'd record a clip on each one
and compare them this is an audio and
video quality test on the lenovo ideapad
s 940 this is an audio and video quality
test on the MacBook Pro and finally
let's finish off with some performance
comparisons and of course we're gonna
start off with a standard Geekbench for
CPU tests so I've got the results and
I'm really surprised because even though
the lenovo has an i7 quad-core processor
it's a lot slower as you can see we're
only getting about 13,000 400 multi-core
score on the lenovo and 18,500 on the
macbook pro that's actually a really
huge difference and with that let's jump
into the graphics test for some reason
every time I try this test on the lenovo
it just keeps canceling out and it
doesn't finish so I looked at the score
online and the difference that we're
seeing between these two machines is
actually quite big I'm really impressed
with the performance of the MacBook Pro
yet again in graphics as well and
finally we're gonna go ahead and run
Cinebench R 20 the tests just finished
and once again we're seeing a massive
difference between these two we're
getting 1807 points on the MacBook Pro
and only 1168 on the lenovo and that's a
massive massive difference I'm not sure
why it's getting such a low score for
being an i7 compared to the i5 so
overall after testing all these things
with these two machines I can definitely
tell you that the MacBook Pro is the
clear winner in so many different areas
and this is what happens when you get a
Windows laptop that decides to use a
unibody aluminum chassis just like the
MacBook Pro it gets a lot more expensive
they both retail at $2,000 but as we've
just seen the performance is much better
on the MacBook Pro the speaker's
absolutely destroy it the trackpad is
top the line destroys it now the display
is better on the lenovo what's also nice
is that you get Windows hello which is
really nice here and the keyboard
definitely feels
better but overall the entire package it
doesn't feel as solid as a macbook pro
and seeing as you're paying the same
amount even if you get this guy on sale
for around two hundred three hundred
dollars off it's still a better deal for
the MacBook Pro because you get Mac OS
it's more reliable it doesn't glitch up
as much you don't get blue screens of
death you don't get errors so overall I
will not recommend this Lenovo to
anybody between these two machines go
for the MacBook Pro every single time so
thanks for watching guys and if you
enjoy this comparison make sure it's
have that like button and click the
circle above to subscribe thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]